marcelina's husband was killed on
Saturday he'd worked in Peru's Minds for
years but she says he had been worried
about this one
I've been thinking about me he said they
are not safe in the mine it is risky
that's what he told me and that's why I
told him why are you going to the mine
what if something happens to you I said
the accident happened at the La
Esperanza mine and arakipa in the early
hours of Saturday local officials say a
short circuit sparked a fire in one of
the tunnels 100 meters Underground
175 workers managed to evacuate but 27
others were killed
a solidarity in condolences with the
families that lost their beloved ones
there's an initial report where the part
of the mine that's affected at least 27
people died today the prosecutor's
office arrived also a police Rescue
Brigade
Marcelina and other relatives rushed to
the remote site as soon as they heard
there had been an accident but this is
as close as they can get
I want to see my husband I want to see
him if you don't allow us we will Rebel
we're dealing with a lot of pain it's a
life it's not any random thing
we want to see his belongings how he
lived where my husband lived that's what
I want
Peru is South America's largest gold
producer and Mining makes up a huge part
of its economy but in the last decade
more than 500 workers have died twice as
high as neighboring Chile
my brother had two children and leaves a
widow we are very dismayed by all that
has happened
but the dark hours of Monday the bodies
of all 27 victims had been recovered
many hope the disaster will shine a
light on the risks that still remain for
workers in one of the world's top mining
countries
Alexandra Byers Al Jazeera